former prime minister gordon brown was a
new labour leader of the country between
2007 and 2010.
back then he was considered moody
sometimes angry i went to scotland to
meet him and find out how he sees the
world now
gordon brown thanks so much for spending
some time with us today we're here to
talk about your book seven ways to
change the world but before we get on to
that and globalization and some of the
challenges climate and so on i did want
to talk to you about things closer to
home things affecting people around your
home in fife and scotland's central belt
evidence of the cost of living crisis
can you describe to me what you're
seeing at the moment
we've now not only got food banks we've
got closed banks
we've got uh betting banks we've got
baby banks
we've got fuel banks
we're now in a situation where charity
is replacing the welfare state as the
last line of defense
the last protection for people in
greatest need
and we're about to go into a winter when
things are going to get in interminably
worse
and already the charities i'm working
with locally are preparing for that
winter by stocking up blankets stocking
up duvets talking up even sleeping bags
hot water bottles because people are
deciding that they can't heat their
homes but they have to
find a way to heat themselves so i don't
think the government
understands the scale of the desolation
and the desperation in communities that
they really don't visit and i think it's
up to us to point out
that unless you have a plan for this
winter and probably to take us through
this cost of living crisis then millions
of people are going to suffer when they
could be helped and at the same time
we're not going to get back
to the growth that is necessary to deal
with the cost of living problems in the
first place so what we need is a plan we
don't know what their pathway is at the
moment they go from one month to the
other the whole purpose of making the
bank of england independent was that
they would take a long-term view of the
future and so we need a
pathway to stable prices sounds like you
find it a bit frustrating watching
what's going on down in westminster at
the moment well i think it's pretty
clear what needs to be done the country
is being asked to accept austerity
because
the wage rises that people are being
offered are way beyond the rate of way
below the rate of inflation uh public
services
are diminishing in many respects as
certain millions of people on health
servers waiting lists and there is no
explanation coming from the government
there is no plan they don't seem to have
a clue what to do now we have global
events that are impinging on us the fuel
crisis obviously globally we've got
obviously uh food crisis globally we've
got debt facing some of the poorest
countries on top of covert climate
change and conflict
and there are things that we can do
globally and we should be taking the
lead but equally you need a national
plan and you need to explain it there
should be a television broadcast by the
prime minister explaining what needs to
be done you cannot go through a winter
when people are being asked to take the
biggest cut in the standards of living
for 50 years and not ask people uh to
understand what you're trying to do and
give them a plan for what they're doing
we are
going to lay out a plan i think before
summer recess though i think they are i
don't think it will be the sort of plan
i'm talking about from what i hear
you've you've got to think
two to three years
it's got to be about growth because the
biggest achilles heel for our economy is
not just the cost of living crisis is
the failure to grow that means that
standards of living have not risen for
10 years
and our public services cannot improve
and so you need to lay out a long-term
plan now it should have been in
actually it should have been in boris
johnson's cbi speech last november when
he talked about peppa pig instead of
talking about an industrial strategy
when he lost his he lost his notes when
he hadn't actually thought through what
the consequences of going through this
winter were going to be
it should have been in the budgets that
richie sunic have done i think he's had
three budgets this year already you
think you should have a fourth don't you
of course because there's got to be a
plan you've got to explain to people
what's happening
you've got to show how you're going to
get back to stable prices you've got to
show also how you're going to help those
people in greatest need the people that
i'm very worried about who are going to
suffer heavily this winter but you've
also got to show you've got a way
through and that's one two three four
years
where you've got to show people that
you've got a plan for growth and a plan
for industry and it's absolutely clear
to me that there is no strategy to do
this and the final thing of course we've
got to do is repair our trading
relations if we cannot repair our
relations with europe and america and
we're at war if you like with both of
them for different reasons but all
related with america well with america
over ireland because america will not
sign a trade treaty with britain as long
as we cannot sort out the issues
relating to ireland president biden i
asked him about this explicitly
last year last september and he did say
that he thought the two things were
separate that there was a trade deal and
then there was the good friday but he
may think that but the american congress
will not think that there's no chance of
a trade deal between britain and america
unless we can sort out the problems that
that arise in in ireland and of course
there's no chance of getting better
trade relationships with europe unless
we can sort these problems
out as well and that's very much part of
our future because if we cannot export
to the leading markets in the world
and cannot do successfully with these
new industries and new technologies then
the cost of living crisis will be with
us for years and not just temporarily
the consequence of a very tight labor
market and inflation has been also a
return to
trade union militancy some would say you
might not but some would say the
government is determined not to
compromise on public sector pay is that
the right stance well what the
government's got to do is get people
around the table and explain to them
what's happening and look if you
couldn't get inflation down in the next
two years from nine percent or eleven
percent now
to three four or two percent then you
can present people with a program you
can say to people here's a package
you're going to benefit later because
your wages will rise as long as we can
take action now but there's nothing of
this in everything they say in fact what
the chancellor is holding out for is the
leadership of the conservative party by
talking about tax cuts all the time
it seems to me though in terms of pay
rises in the short term you seem to
agree with the prime minister this is
what he said to me
at choggam when i asked him about pay
rises for public sector workers he said
what we can't have is a situation in
which increases in pay are wiped out by
further increases in prices that's why
you've got to be responsible
he's right isn't he that wage increases
could lead to an inflation rate but you
but he's talking about a situation where
he's
trying to allege that some groups of
workers are leapfrogging over other
groups of workers that this is a sort of
uh
traditional wage bargaining run where
people are trying to get ahead of others
all the time in fact everybody in the
country is facing a cut in the standards
of living and he's got to explain to
people how if he's asking them to accept
sacrifice now what he's going to do for
them to benefit later so what you might
say you're going to have to take three
percent this year but next year i will
try and increase it to x percent or
well i'm not going to get in the
business of figures because these are
parts
you should actually understand that your
former chance so you get this
look if we could get back to growth and
that would be let's say two and a half
or three percent growth coming out of
this
then that's an extra 50 or 60 billion a
year for the economy that's an extra 20
billion of revenues for the for the
exchequer to pay for the things that we
need we need to pay for including
helping people who are in difficulty and
what i think is missing is any sense of
the long term
you know this is a this is a prime
minister who thinks only from scandal to
scandal or crisis to crisis and it's
really sad
you don't hold him in
much regard do you i don't i don't want
to be personal i know but i think it's
only because you've said a few things
about the peppa pig and not having a
plan i was using peppa pig and look he
went to the cbi and people were
expecting to set out a policy for
industry for the future
probably the most favorable audience he
he he could get if i had been there i
would have been setting up my policy for
industry and and for growth and he not
only lost his his notes in his way but
he but he definitely lost his way in
terms of any direction and
and really since last november when
we've had three budgets uh consequent to
that there has been no strategy and no
plan and it's really important for for
any country going through these
difficulties to explain these are global
factors that we we are trying to control
but we're working collectively now it's
no good the chances are the prime
minister saying they're beyond our
control most of these global forces can
be managed by international cooperation
but at home i think the lack of a plan
and the lack of a sense of direction is
really what is the beginning of this
government yeah my only observation was
you don't seem to think he's a very
serious guy i mean that's the impression
you believe in me
beth you're trying to get me to be
personal about these these are really
big issues of i just think people
watching it
now if you ask me would i have been
organizing parties in downing street no
and i didn't and people asked me why
there were no parties in down history
but but equally i i don't want to to to
to relegate this this is an issue of
policy affecting the standards of living
of millions of people across this
country also affecting the health
service and our ability to finance it
where i think we could do better and
affecting the general level of public
service let's move on
to your book and some of the global
issues now that you have been thinking
quite deeply about the seven ways to
change the world in the book you
identify seven grave dangers that
require global solutions that was in
2021 now in the early summer of 22
you've written a new prologue um of your
book which boils down to three really
three issues covered climate and war
but isn't what is happening now in
ukraine
of those three existential issues isn't
it now really that one issue in that
there's an argument that says
that we can't deal with anything on the
social democratic agenda
domestically or internationally until
that situation in ukraine is settled
that it literally just
blankets out everything else well let me
say first of all after this shopping
center massacre that has been taking
place in the last day and the numbers of
deaths
clearly a pre-meditated attack
organized by putin himself
to scare the ukrainian people
there is no argument now against
holding him responsible for this
bringing him before a war crimes
tribunal indicting him
and the best way to do that would be to
set up a special tribunal now ahead of
the international criminal court
arraignment for the crime of aggression
which is provable and demonstrable
without having to go into a huge amount
of evidence about individual cases of
war atrocities
and he should be indicted and he should
be charged and even in his absence he
should be found guilty and so should the
cabal around them there is no there is
nothing that putin understands other
than strength there is nothing he
understands other than
uh us showing that we are prepared to
stand up to him and that he will exploit
every weakness that we show and i know
that from looking at his record and
having uh worked
in the time that he was prime minister
and president and i was prime minister
and i think we've got to send out a very
clear message that none of these crimes
can go with impunity
so you don't think that there should be
a process waiting for you you think that
there should be an expedited process to
charge him as a war criminal i think
that the crime
the crime of aggression
is obviously no i think he does care but
the problem is mr brown partly that if
you look at how many countries around
the world have actually sanctioned
russia it's 20 of the world
can you coalesce
the world to charge putin or the world's
divided on this so this is what has
happened we've got nato unity
but we've got global disunity
so 82 countries either abstained or
voted with russia when they were brought
before the human rights council for
violations of human rights as you say
about 150 countries are not imposing
sanctions
and the reason i think goes back to some
of the events of the last few years why
is it almost the whole of africa the
whole of asia
latin america
mexico and brazil included in latin
america
much of the middle east are refusing to
impose sanctions or to take any action
against uh
putin and it's because
they feel first of all double standards
i think they feel that we we are
concerned about ukraine but not about
civil wars that happen in other
countries but second that they don't
feel
they do not feel that the globalization
that has been led by the west is really
working in their favor going back to
ukraine before we move on
uh the prime minister's view
is that ukraine shouldn't be coerced
into what he would describe as a bad
piece and he's worried that
the economic fallout of this war
might compel other countries to now
try and force
or encourage ukraine into
a piece in which perhaps some of the
land is annexed what's your view of that
do you agree with boris johnson on that
i i agree with him about the importance
of making sure
that we do everything in our power to
protect the sovereignty of ukraine what
i think however is is missing here is is
the greater coordination in policy now
there's been a huge amount of
coordination in terms of
the first round of sanctions there's
been a huge amount of coordination in
terms of saying we'll give you this or
that military support i think boris
johnson perhaps should spend more time
trying to bring people together to agree
on what the objectives are for the next
stage of this of this enterprise and of
course we want to support ukraine and of
course there is a there is there is an
issue about where you move from a
defensive position that is you're
helping ukraine defend itself to what
russia would see as aggression uh but
these are things that i think we've got
to discuss together and i think
there is a danger that america britain
germany france italy all go in different
directions over the next year
kierstama he
is the labour leader obviously
the question i want to ask you is do you
think he sealed the deal with the
british public
in that
some of his colleagues as you will know
have sort of criticized kierstarma for
being too boring to quote them
um
it's kind of a bit true he does does he
come across as a bit boring a bit
loyally
not a charismatic leader i think every
question i think every criticism that
has been visited on uh kiestama was
visited on me tony blair jim calligan
uh harry people didn't call tony blair
boring did they yeah but they they did
say that labour didn't have an exciting
enough agenda at certain points i mean
you remember in 1997 people said it was
too modest and and everything else but
all these criticisms are thrown at labor
leaders and and they're mainly thrown of
course by a conservative press that's
gotten interested in defeating the
labour party uh my advice to to give
someone is usually not to take my advice
because it's better that he does his own
thing but my advice to him has always
been not to l not to listen to this and
to get on with the job that he said
himself one one to to prepare the party
so that it's seen by the public as a
national party that's capable of
representing the whole country secondly
to develop his policy
and third to put across his policy to as
wide a group of people as possible and
that includes talking to no voters in
scotland
as yes voters as well as no voters in
scotland and it includes talking to
lead voters as well as remain voters in
england we've got to find a way of
bringing this country together and i
think kia stammer is better placed to do
that than boris johnson do you think the
prime minister lacks integrity clearly
uh he
he he has broken the law uh clearly he
has uh has failed to follow the rules
fairly fairly he's evaded his own
ministerial code all these things are
true and i think he's admitted that to
be the case the question i think
that he didn't quite answer at the
weekend is whether he's going to change
would you have resigned if you were him
at this point well i couldn't i'll look
i'll be honest i could not have imagined
myself
breaking
the law in downing street during during
a a crisis like like we've had and
therefore i i i could not have stayed in
office if i thought i'd let people down
in that way i've got to ask you this
scottish independence do you think that
there will be a second referendum in
your lifetime or my lifetime
i i wouldn't rule out that but i would
say that scotland deserves better than
what's happening at the moment i mean
we're in a endless debate about
constitutional details that is leading
us nowhere
i would like to see and i would like to
put forward a far more ambitious plan
for the future of scotland one that
solves some of the constitutional
difficulties deals with the economic
challenges we face
builds a far better social fabric for
this country and that's really the issue
for the people of scotland if the issue
is posed as change
through independence versus no change
and the only alternative is independence
then independence will will will be
something that people would be prepared
to consider
but if it's one kind of change for
scotland staying within britain but in a
better situation both in terms of its
economic
social and political future
as against independence then the change
that is within britain will win
do you think kirsten will be the next
prime minister of this country yes i do
do you really yes i do
okay thank you thanks for your time